MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
PETER LUBBERS: Hello, and
welcome to the Chrome
Developer Channel on Google
Developer Live.
Really excited to
be here today.
In the studio, we
have Jan Linden.
And on air from Seattle,
we have Chris Wilson.
I'm Peter Lubbers, the program
manager in the Chrome
Developer Relations team.
Jan, can you tell us a little
bit about what you do at
Google before we get started?
JAN LINDEN: Absolutely.
So I'm on the Chrome team.
I am a product manager that
focuses on everything audio in
Chrome, which is really
exciting.
Because there's happening a
lot in this area, and in
particular, the Web Audio API
that we're talked about today
is really bringing the web to
a new level that we haven't
seen before.
PETER LUBBERS: Thanks.
And coming to us from Seattle,
Chris Wilson.
Chris, can you tell us a little
bit about what you do
at Google, and how you got
involved with web audio?
CHRIS WILSON: Sure, Peter.
So I'm on the Chrome Developer
Relations team.
In short, that means I get to
play with all the neat stuff
that Jan and his team put
together and build some neat
demos, come up with different
ways of using it, push
feedback back to him.
And more than anything, work
with other developers on what
they want to build and what they
want to get out of the
API and other APIs as
well, of course.
So that's kind of what I
do on a daily basis.
As for how I got into web
audio, it was really--
I got really interested when I
started seeing the ability to
build software synthesizers
and processing units and
things like that.
It had been something I'd
started getting very
interested in.
Just because in the last decade
or so, all of this neat
hardware that I grew up with
really as a keyboard player,
suddenly you could actually
replicate it all in software
relatively easily.
And the Web Audio API letting
you do that in an even easier
software way was really
exciting to me.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
Excellent.
Well, and full disclosure, I
don't know all that much about
Web Audio myself, but I got to
carry Chris's speakers at
Google I/O. And my youngest
son is an aspiring DJ.
CHRIS WILSON: Everybody
needs roadies.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
All right.
So a quick agenda--
so we're going to talk--
and I mentioned this is the
first of a two-part series.
In the first one, we'll talk
about mostly an introductory
session about what Web Audio is,
how you can use it in your
applications.
And in the second one, which
will be in a few weeks-- we'll
announce it on our
Google+ page--
we'll talk more about how you
can use Web Audio in games.
Chris is going to show a demo.
That demo will be available on
GitHub, so for sure check it
out after the event.
So without further ado, Chris,
do you want to start off
talking about Web Audio?
CHRIS WILSON: Sure.
So I gave a talk at Google
I/O on the Web Audio API.
And I wanted to run through just
a couple of the slides
from that because it sort of
helps capture, for me, what
the Web Audio API is.
I want to show off probably two
of the demos that I built
for Google I/O. And then we'll
open it up to the floor from
there, I think.
But I do recommend, if you want
more detail about how Web
Audio is put together, go watch
the YouTube video of the
talk that I gave or run
through the slides.
They're all publicly
available.
And like you said, all the demos
that I have are actually
up on GitHub and posted today.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Actually, just before you dive
into it, Chris, the moderator
link is linked on the Google
Developers Live page for this
event, for those of you
that haven't seen it.
Scroll down to the bottom
of the page.
Currently, we have six questions
with 65 votes, so
we'll take those afterwards.
But you can still ask additional
questions.
All right.
Over to you.
CHRIS WILSON: OK, so let me flip
to my slide deck here.
So the first question that
always comes up when I try to
describe the Web Audio API to
people is, why do we even need
another audio API?
We now have this great audio
element that we've had for a
few years now, but even that
took a long time for us to get
implemented across
all the browsers.
Because prior to that, we had
proprietary bgsound stuff that
wasn't really controllable
and wasn't a great
way of doing audio.
And the audio element
is great.
I don't want anyone walking away
thinking that we want to
move people away from
the audio tag.
Because it actually is a really
easy way to wrap up
these steps of loading,
decoding, and playing audio
all into one.
And you get a set of controls
right there.
The user can click the Play
button, and it plays.
It shows you where you are
in the sound file.
You've got volume controls and
all that kind of stuff.
And of course, you can hook
in and control those
yourself, if you want.
But the problem that we have
with that is that you don't
really have this fine-grained
control ability.
Like, you can scrub in the
audio and play from a
particular place in
the audio file.
But you don't have the
ability to do this
very precise timing.
Because it packages up this
loading, decoding, and playing
step altogether.
So when you hit the button to
play a sound, it doesn't
necessarily play it right at
that millisecond, or sub
millisecond, even more
interestingly.
So Web Audio lets you do this
very precise timing.
You can have lots of overlapping
sounds as well.
[VIDEO GAME SHOOTING
NOISE WITH REVERB]
CHRIS WILSON: And it's really
easy to set that
up inside the API.
But secondly, even more
interestingly, the Web Audio
API provides an audio pipeline,
a routing system,
and a bunch of effects and
filters, so that you can very
easily do different things
with your audio.
You can filter it.
You can add reverb effects.
You can add all kinds of
echo or delay effects.
[SHOOTING NOISE WITH ECHO]
CHRIS WILSON: And it's pretty
easy to set those up.
Inside this deck, by the way,
all of these things are live
HTML demos.
So it's pretty easy to dig in
and look at what they say.
Later in the deck-- which I'm
not going to go into--
there's a ton of code in there,
so you can see how I'm
setting up these effects.
And then finally, the Web Audio
API has a bunch of hooks
to visualize audio data and
manipulate it on the fly.
So it's not just a static, hey,
you have an MP3 file.
Hit Play and it'll
come out through
somebody's speaker somewhere.
You can actually do things like
analyze it on a frequency
basis and get kind of the
standard graphic equalizer
view of the audio.
Now, on top of that,
there were really--
oops, sorry.
There we go.
The API itself is actually
defined at
a pretty high level.
So it's really easy to do
basic things like--
COMPUTER: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: --playing
a single sound.
That's the code for
it right there.
I just create a buffer source.
I set it to the right buffer,
connect it to the speakers,
and start playing it.
And even doing effects
and filters--
what I have in this code is
essentially exactly the code
from that last slide
when I hit Fire.
And it had an echo effect.
You don't need to understand
low-level audio digital signal
processing in order to
use these things.
In fact, I'm not an
audio engineer.
And if I had to go build a whole
bunch of matrices and
build my own or even directly
use an FFT transform to get
these audio effects to work,
I'm pretty sure I would go
find something else
to play with.
Because that just seems like
a lot of hard work.
But at the same time, of course,
if you want to do
that, there is a way to do
very low-level API custom
audio processing directly
in JavaScript.
You can sit there and
manipulate the bits
individually if you want to.
Now--
come on--
one of our big goals--
and this never works well in
screen sharing, so I'd
encourage you to go look at
this in the slide deck
yourself on your own machine.
But the biggest thing that we
were really trying to do was
make audio and audio processing
independent of all
the other stuff that's
going on.
We push all of our native audio
processing off into a
separate high-priority thread,
which means doing even complex
audio shouldn't cause glitches
in the visuals.
Like I said, I'm not going to
run through this demo here,
just because in screen sharing,
it doesn't work
particularly well.
But I wanted to give a really
high-level view of some of the
features that we needed to
supply for gaming purposes and
some of the features we
needed to supply for
more musical purposes.
And then I'll show a quick demo
or two that I've built.
So I already mentioned you need
very precise timing for
many simultaneous sounds.
Games typically have tons and
tons of effects going on at
the same time.
And the HTML audio element
doesn't really scale to having
lots of sounds.
Half a dozen is OK.
But 25 or so-- it starts
getting kind of wonky.
And of course, you need
very precise timing.
When you hit Fire, you want
to hear the fire almost
immediately.
But we also need features like
3D spatialization, placing
sounds in a sound field.
Doppler shift--
If you drive past a police
officer in a driving game, you
want to hear the siren
change pitch.
And doing things like automatic
distance attenuation
and sound directionality, so you
can hear where a sound is
in a virtual environment.
And it sounds very realistic.
You also need lots of
filtering effects to
automatically make audio sound
like it's being blocked by a
wall, or like it's coming over
a radio or a telephone.
This is the same sound file
that I played before.
COMPUTER: Play sound now.
CHRIS WILSON: --but it sounds
like it's coming over a
telephone, even if you have a
really high-quality audio
connection, which we don't
right now, but.
And then finally, of course,
you need acoustic
environments.
If you walk into a large room
and fire your BFG9000, it
should sound different than if
you're in a tiny little closet
and you fire it.
And of course, for both gaming
and music, we need the ability
to create kind of scheduled
sound events.
We need to create sequences or
loops or things like that.
But we also need to automate
things like
fade-ins and fade-outs.
Now, for music, there are a
few kind of basic sound
elements that you need for
musical applications.
You may or may not use them
in gaming applications.
Sometimes games record all
their music or effects.
And they're all sound buffers.
Sometimes they actually do
want to create the sound
effects using oscillators.
So oscillators let you create
sine waves and sawtooth waves
and things like that, and set
frequency and change the
frequency and that
sort of thing.
Music also uses a lot of
dynamics processing.
So this is usually referred to
as compression and expansion.
If you look at-- this is
actually a picture of one of
the racks in my music
studio at home.
And one of the units in this
is actually a hardware
compressor.
So a piece of hardware that
actually does this one
particular processing.
We also need to do things
like distortion effects.
One of the other units there
is a guitar amp processor.
And a lot of that is actually
just applying very carefully
designed distortion
to a sound.
And then as we mentioned before,
you need a lot of
frequency and waveform analysis
kind of features.
So the first demo that I wanted
to show is actually--
this is the Web Audio playground
is what I ended up
calling this.
And this basically is just
a way for you to visually
explore what you can do with
the Web Audio API.
So I can do things like add an
audio buffer source, connect
it to the speakers,
and hit Play.
[BELL DINGS]
CHRIS WILSON: And--
whoops.
And I can--
hm.
I can restart.
I obviously missed one of my
embedded features there.
I can create something.
I can do a-- oh, let's show
one of our neat frequency
analyzers and connect
this guy up.
And let's loop it.
[DRUM BEAT]
CHRIS WILSON: And you can
see what it looks
like in real time.
I can also do things like add
a filter node in there.
And just for kicks, let's toss
another frequency analyzer so
we can see what it looks like.
Sorry, this is running on kind
of a smaller screen than I
usually play with this.
But now that I've got this all
connected, I can hit Play--
[DRUM BEAT CONTINUES]
CHRIS WILSON: --and change the
parameters of my filter.
And you can actually see what it
does in real time, as well
as hear it.
So you can get some neat kind of
musical effects, as well as
the filters are the same thing
that I used to create that
telephone filter before.
So this is kind of just a way
to play around with all the
different types of audio nodes
that are in the Web Audio API.
So you can play with the delay
node, the compressor node,
[? convolver ?]
for doing reverb and
stuff like that.
But I wanted to create a little
bit more interesting
demo of this myself.
So I created a vocoder.
This is actually one of the
first things that I set out to
see if I could actually build
this using Web Audio.
And a vocoder is an interesting
process.
It's been around for
a long time.
It's basically the robot
voice effect.
And what vocoding does is it
takes one sound file or one
sound input, usually referred to
as the modulator, which is
frequently somebody speaking.
So it's something like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Four score and seven
years ago.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
CHRIS WILSON: And it maps the
frequency characteristics,
which you can see on
the screen here.
It maps the frequency
characteristics over time.
And it applies the frequency
envelopes to a different
sound, called the carrier, which
is usually some kind of
frequency-rich synthesized
sound, like this one.
[BUZZING]
And no, that's not an error or
a disconnected audio input.
It actually does sound
like that.
But when you map these
together-- when you take the
input of the modulator and you
apply it onto the carrier
signal, you get something
that sounds like a
robotic voice, like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Four score and seven years ago,
our fathers brought forth
on this continent,
a new nation--
CHRIS WILSON: Now, the really
cool thing about this, to me,
is this is all happening
in real time.
The Web Audio API is actually
doing everything
here in real time.
In fact, I set up this big graph
of nodes and plugged
them all together.
And then the only thing that
my JavaScript code is doing
while this is running is
doing those visuals.
Showing you what's going on in
the frequency analysis by
mapping it.
This means that I can change
things in real time, too.
So I can change the pitch
of the carrier signal.
[PITCH OF ROBOT SPEECH
CHANGES]
CHRIS WILSON: And I can
also add more noise
to the signal, or--
[SIGNAL GETS MORE DISTORTED]
CHRIS WILSON: --do other
things like that.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
CHRIS WILSON: So there's a lot
of dynamics to this whole
thing, like everything is
happening in real time.
And I've done a bunch of
tweaking work behind the
scenes to set this process up.
But once the process is going,
all I have to do is go in and
change parameters on the Web
Audio API nodes to make new
things happen.
So this was the first demo
that I was building.
And it was kind of one of these
journeys, because I
spent a ton of time just digging
through and starting
to understand more and more
what a vocoder does.
I was very, very naive when
I started building this.
And I think Chris Rogers, the
engineer on the project--
I think he didn't want
to tell me that I was
in way over my head.
But he helped me kind of dig my
way out, and managed to get
my head above water
eventually.
So this was kind
of a cool demo.
There are a bunch of things
that I'm really looking
forward to building and
adding to this demo
as well in the future.
So I'm kind of excited to see
what other demos can get built
from that space.
And I think, as we mentioned
earlier, by the way, the code
for this is available
on GitHub.
In fact, if you just go
to github.com/cwilso--
C-W-I-L-S-O--
you'll find a bunch of different
audio demos that
I've been building lately.
And with that, I think
I'll bring it back.
And we can maybe start looking
at some of the questions.
PETER LUBBERS: Sure.
Just a quick question.
What were some of the main
issues you ran into?
Or are there any specific tips
that you would want to share
after building that
great demo?
What are some of the highlights
of that, or some of
the things you should
say, well, really,
watch out for this?
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
The number one thing that I
would encourage people to do,
if you're going to do more
than just very basic--
I want to play very precisely
timed sounds.
The number one thing I would say
is, figure out very early
on, like, package up
a visual analyzer.
Figure out how to use the
real-time analyzer node and be
able to use that as kind of an
oscilloscope to see what's
going on in your code.
It helps so dramatically to be
able to see what the frequency
analysis is over time.
And during the course of me
having this Web Audio vocoder
code that I was in the process
of building, I would have four
or five frequency analyzers on
the screen so I could see what
was happening between
each step.
And I could tell, oh, wait, this
isn't actually affecting
the sound in the way
that I want it to.
Or my frequency bands aren't
really very well defined.
I need to up the order of the
filters that I'm using, or
something like that.
And it was fantastically helpful
for that purpose.
I think other than that, there
weren't any huge gotchas that
I ran into early on.
Mostly it turns out that
a vocoder is a
very finicky beast.
And you have to sit there and
tweak all of the volume levels
and the gain levels throughout
the whole thing.
And you have to very carefully
filter things at the
appropriate times to make it
sound good, because it turns
out it's not just a well-defined
process.
It's actually kind of a
very musical effect.
And you have to tune it
musically in order to make it
sound good in that context.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
Yeah, I really liked what
you did with the
visualizations of it.
Did you use Canvas
for that or--
CHRIS WILSON: So that one,
actually, I shamelessly stole
straight from Chris Rogers.
He had built a visualizer,
I think fairly
early on in Web Audio.
And it uses WebGL to draw
the whole 3D mapping and
everything.
And the great thing about that
one, though, is it actually
tracks it over time,
so you can see.
The vocoder bars in the middle,
those are just a
capture of what's going on in
my code or in the vocoder
code, like tracking what the
frequency envelopes look like.
But when I originally
built it, I built my
own frequency analyzer.
Because I wanted to see where
exactly are my frequency bands
in relation to the frequency
analysis.
I set up a frequency analyzer
that looked very much like the
frequency analyzer that I played
with the drum sound
during the slide deck.
It looked like that, but
it drew vertical
bars, so I could see--
this is the center
of each of the
frequency bands in my vocoder.
And I could tell, wait a second,
this isn't lining up
to the right place, or
things like that.
It was super helpful.
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
This was real exciting to see.
Chris, I don't want to downplay
your abilities, but
you're not exactly a signal
processing guy that knows
exactly about all
these things.
CHRIS WILSON: I am absolutely
not a signal processing guy.
JAN LINDEN: And the fact
that you could build
this is pretty amazing.
So it shows the capabilities of
this, and how much of the
hard stuff has been done
under the hood.
And using, as you said, the
tools of the frequency
analyzer to understand step by
step what you're doing makes
it possible to then fiddle
around and figure it out
without having to get into all
the details, and still come up
with this excellent result.
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
I think in retrospect, the hard
part, and the parts where
I spent the bulk of my time
building that demo, were not
building the Web Audio graph
to handle the sound
processing.
The biggest thing that I spent a
lot of time in was tweaking.
And there's actually--
if you go into the developer
tools while it's running, you
can actually find there's
a div with a
huge number of sliders.
I think it has about 20 sliders
still in it that were
just letting me tweak gain
levels throughout the process
of this thing.
And if you do things like give
it a different sound file that
isn't the same average volume
level, you may have to
re-tweak some of those things.
Because I didn't make
automatic volume
detection in it.
But really, it was that and
building a good-looking user
experience that took the
bulk of the time.
PETER LUBBERS: That's
excellent.
You definitely succeeded
in that.
Great.
So let's take a couple
questions.
So the first question on the
moderator is, will the API be
cross-browser compatible out of
the box, or will we have to
deal with vendor prefixes?
JAN LINDEN: Well, we will.
CHRIS WILSON: Always
a fun question.
So out of the box is an
interesting point, because Web
Audio has actually been in
Chrome for quite a while now.
It's been shipping and
[? stable ?] for--
before I was on the team.
JAN LINDEN: Yeah,
Chrome 13 or 14.
I can't remember, but
one of those.
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
Sounds about right.
And it is WebKit prefixed.
It is vendor prefixed today.
Although it is vendor prefixed
at the point where you say, I
want an audio context.
Like, I want to use
the Web Audio API.
Give me a handle to it.
And from then on, you don't
have WebKit prefixes
everywhere.
So hopefully, we'll end up with
an API that is very easy
to say, well, if you don't have
audio context, get WebKit
audio context.
And then most of it just
works after that.
As far as other browsers
adopting it, we've spent a lot
of time, and I think we've seen
a lot of movement in the
last five to six months,
probably, from other vendors
being very interested and
actively participating in the
API on the working group.
The Mozilla guys have been
involved in the Web Audio
working group, I think
since the beginning,
certainly for a long time.
Opera has jumped in, and given
a lot of feedback on the API,
which has been great.
Microsoft team has been
looking at Web Audio.
I feel like we're really pushing
very hard to move this
to something that is
cross-vendor and
cross-platform as well.
And right now, actually, in
Safari 6 in beta, and in iOS 6
Safari, we have support for
Web Audio, as well.
Granted, it's still
built on WebKit.
It's still WebKit
vendor prefixed.
But we do have it on a different
platform and
delivered from a different
vendor.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
That question, by the
way, was from Ling.
Another question that was voted
up quite a bit was a
little bit about security.
So the question was from tr67.
What security measures need
to be taken in the
future for Web Audio?
Are audio popups a threat?
And how would subsequent
blocking techniques affect us
as developers?
Sure, anyone can hit a Mute
button, but what if a browser
is locked down completely?
So, Jan, do you want to
take a stab at that?
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
It's a very interesting
question.
And actually, I'll start with
something that is not part of
Web Audio API right now,
but something we are
working hard on adding.
And that's input audio, as
well, through another API
called Get User Media,
which is right now
available in Chrome.
But they haven't been
hooked up yet.
But that means that you can
take input audio and then
process it, do an analysis, et
cetera, and directly either
play it out or just do whatever
you want with it.
And there, you definitely have
some interesting aspects of
privacy and security,
which have been
discussed and resolved.
So we've been able
to ship that.
But of course, then you have
to allow the microphone to
record what you're doing.
So there is a whole process
similar to getting location
data, et cetera,
in other APIs.
So that part has been
taken care of.
It will, of course, always be
a little bit clumsy in the
sense that the first time you go
to a domain, you will have
to allow it.
But then you can have always
allow for that one, if it's a
secure HTTP.
So that side is something that
I think people would be very
worried about, but it
is taken care of.
On the popups--
maybe, Chris, you've thought
more about that?
That's obviously--
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
I mean, I think for
output, it's a
really interesting question.
And I'm probably an interesting
person to
have it asked of.
Because despite being super
excited by the Web Audio API,
I'm the guy who--
my laptop is always muted.
I don't want to be in the middle
of a meeting and have
it start playing music or
something like that.
But also, I just don't
particularly like going to
websites and having
them play funky
background music or whatever.
So it's kind of a weird space
to be saying, hey, let's go
build this audio stuff into
the web platform.
I think that it is a
general concern.
I don't think it's really a
denial of service, because you
can always just hit the Mute
button on your machine.
I don't think the browser would
be completely locked
down in a situation where you
wouldn't want the user to have
access to the Mute button, like
a library system or a
kiosk system or something
like that.
Those are always going
to be options
unless it's simply disabled.
So I think that it is an
interesting question to handle
in the broader sense of what do
we do with audio elements
and bgsound and stuff
like that.
But I don't think it's
relevant just to
Web Audio by itself.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
Yeah.
That's definitely
a good question.
So another question was from--
let's see--
maxw3st.
What audio file formats
does the API handle?
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
So in Chrome, we support AAC,
MP3, WAV files, and OGG.
And then for other platforms,
that depends
on what they support.
But basically, what you will do
is you support the same as
you do for the audio element.
And that could obviously be
added more in the future.
But these are, right now, the
ones that are the popular ones
and the ones that we
want to support.
But we are continuously looking
at if there are new
ones we can add at a later
time, if there is enough
reason for doing so.
PETER LUBBERS: Another
question is
from Tony-b from France.
Multichannel support--
how many, and what precision and
regularity for looping a
small sound a few milliseconds
long is available?
I think you dealt with
that extensively.
CHRIS WILSON: Right.
So multichannel support
is definitely--
there's two versions
of multichannel.
There's the can I get access
to stereo, or 5.1 surround
sound, or things like that.
Support for that is actually
built into the Web Audio API.
One of the demos I did for IO
was a left-right stereo
ping-pong delay, showing that
you could actually hook in and
control that.
There's also sort of the
multi-context support, like
the idea that I want to have two
separate audio outputs on
my computer, and be able to
control independently what
goes to each one of them.
A classic example of this for me
is one of the side projects
that I'm working on
is building tools
for doing disc jockeying.
And DJs typically have one audio
output that's going to
the main speakers.
And then they have
their headphones.
So you need to have two very
separate audio outputs,
because they send different
things to
those different speakers.
Like, they have a button on
their deck that says, play
this to my headphones, so they
can queue something up but not
let everyone hear it.
And I think that we need to have
that kind of capability.
It is a concept that has been
considered, I think, from the
very beginning of the API, but
we don't currently have
support for it yet.
As for the other side of that
question, what precision and
regularity for looping small
sounds, you absolutely can do
this essentially down
to the sample level.
All of our durations
are in seconds.
And they're floating
point numbers.
So you can go in and say, I
want to loop this from the
first sample to the last sample,
and it can only be--
you can say, this is only
100 samples long.
So 1/100 of whatever
the number of
samples per second is.
And I've actually done that.
I used an extremely short sound
buffer to replicate--
I think it was a sine wave,
before we got the oscillator
up and running inside
the code.
So it's very precise.
And the precision for duration
is just as precise.
PETER LUBBERS: Awesome.
All right.
One question I had as well,
and it was asked on the
moderator--
what are the options for
recording, archiving, and
playing back audio
conversations?
In fact, I was thinking
it would be great--
I don't know if it's even
added to your demo.
Once you've looped all these
things together, and you've
created that sound that you
liked, is it even possible in
your demo--
the first demo you showed--
to download or to save it?
CHRIS WILSON: So today, in both
of those demos, you can't
actually save the output
of it, [? trivially. ?]
You can use a loopback audio
output and record it with
different software, but
it's not built in.
Today, I believe we don't have
any way natively to record it
and encode it into one
of those formats--
into OGG or WAV or MP3--
but that's certainly something
we've discussed.
You could actually build a
JavaScript audio node that
captures data and stores that
in any form you want.
It can store it as just an
audio buffer, which, of
course, is trivial to store,
or write your own code to
re-encode it as an mp3, or
whatever format you want.
JAN LINDEN: So right now, that
would be the biggest problem.
And doing an encoding can
be fairly complex.
So JavaScript encoder--
there are potentials to
do that, absolutely.
The other way that is being
worked on, again, using the
Get User Media API,
as I mentioned--
that one will get a recording
function into it.
It's a [? standardization ?]
process right now to figure out
how, exactly, that should
be done, but that's
also in the works.
So then you can both record
directly what's coming in, but
also feed what's the output from
Web Audio API into a Get
User Media that can then
record or play out
whatever you want.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
And Get User Media, also
very important
for WebRTC, of course.
JAN LINDEN: Exactly.
PETER LUBBERS: All
right, excellent.
Another question from Gerwin
Sturm from Vienna.
How does the Web Audio API
compare to the Audio Data API
available in Firefox?
Are there already libraries
to support both for
cross-browser support?
And will they be merged to one
standard in the long run?
Who wants to take that?
JAN LINDEN: Yeah.
So basically, I think Mozilla
has moved on from that.
The idea is that the Web Audio
API is the main API people are
working on in the future.
So that's where the focus
is on everybody's side.
But there is still--
for the Firefox data
API, there is the
potential to use it.
And there are JavaScript
libraries
that do connect both.
So you could use it.
But since it is based on doing
everything in JavaScript, it's
much more limited in terms of
what you can do in real time.
And therefore, not all
functionality that you can do
in Web Audio API is available
for the simple [? data ?]
API.
CHRIS WILSON: The Audio Data
API is really just about
getting audio input
and output.
It's not about providing a
routing and effects pipeline.
And so you can use it.
And there certainly
are libraries that
are using it today.
Mozilla has actually stated
publicly several times that
I've seen that audio data
is not something they're
interested in continuing.
They were working on a
MediaStreams audio proposal
for a while.
And a lot of the guidance
from that is folded into
the Web Audio API.
And they continue to work-- we
all continue to work on that
in the Web Audio
working group.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
A couple of other questions--
so how does Web
Audio relate to WebRTC?
We touched on it briefly
with Get User Media.
Will Web Audio eventually become
a component of WebRTC?
How do you see that
fitting together?
JAN LINDEN: No is the
simple answer.
They're both extremely important
separate APIs.
WebRTC--
that's my background.
I've been working with
RTC forever.
And I come from the company that
brought this technology
into Google.
Anyway, so I'm working
on that as well.
And that is evolving in its
own way and will become
everything you need for doing
real-time voice and video
communication.
Then you will add Web Audio
API to this, either at the
input or at the output.
So at the input, it can be
interesting to add effects.
So between the microphone and
the encoder that you will send
data to the other side in
WebRTC, there you can add, for
example, an effect so you sound
differently, or whatever
you want to do--
filtering and things
like that.
And then on the output, it's
really nice to be able to add
what Web Audio API can do in
terms of spatialization.
For example, if you think about
a conferencing solution
where you want different
participants to come from
different locations, that's
easy to do that way.
And again, add effects,
et cetera.
So actually, the way WebRTC
is being specced out and
designed, it's assumed that Web
Audio API will be there
and take care of these things.
So WebRTC will not include, for
example, spatialization,
because it's not needed.
So they are really working
together to accomplish the
goals of all the audio
you want to have.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
Another question from
stephband--
so the obvious next step for
the vocoder is to give it
real-time input.
Where are we with being able
to send audio into
Chrome in real time?
It's on GitHub, right?
CHRIS WILSON: Well, no.
I've been pestering--
I'll put it politely
as pestering--
Jan and Chris about this for
probably about six months now.
And I think I've sent at least
two mails in the last couple
of weeks to Chris, saying, you
know, the instant you guys
have any build that has
audio input support,
please give it to me.
Because I'm going to
go immediately hook
it up to the vocoder.
It is coming.
It is something that the team's
actively working on and
hopefully will be at least
initially implemented pretty
quickly here.
But it's not quite there yet.
I will guarantee that I'll get
it into the vocoder as quickly
as possible.
JAN LINDEN: So the work is going
on right now, both on
the Web Audio side and the
WebRTC, because we want to do
both of these things.
But basically, the first case
we are implementing is this
case to get live audio
into Web Audio API.
And you never know exactly
when it's done.
But we're working as quickly
as possible,
and it's a high priority.
And we have people working
on it today.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
All right, a question from
Jeff in Portland.
With Web Audio, can I play a
long audio file, like a song,
and synchronize JavaScript
events to be fired at certain
times in the song?
For example, having a function
that gets called when the
audio file reaches the
three-second mark--
something like that.
Is that possible?
CHRIS WILSON: So that's an
interesting use case.
I think that you'll probably
find the best way to do that
is to use tracks in the HTML5
audio element and then if you
want processing on top of that,
you can actually get the
output of an audio element
and push it into
the Web Audio graphs.
You can use that as a sound
source in Web Audio as well,
if you want reverb or something
on the audio file.
We don't actually have callbacks
from the functions.
Because the audio in the Web
Audio API is running on the
audio system clock, which may or
may not be the same as your
computer clock.
If you have a totally separate
audio interface internally, it
probably has literally a
separate crystal for the clock
to keep it stable.
And callbacks would actually
cause some interesting timing
challenges there.
But you can synchronize
JavaScript events fairly
easily, simply by saying, well,
this is going to happen
in 15 seconds.
So I'm going to set a callback
for 15 seconds.
But tracks is really the way
to do that inside the HTML5
audio element.
JAN LINDEN: And if you want to
do something like your own
analysis based on the
[? signal, ?] you can still
hook up the audio tag to the
Web Audio API, and then use
the JavaScript node to do your
analysis, and whatever you
want to fire on that.
PETER LUBBERS: So a couple final
questions here, then.
And if I missed any, I will go
back through the moderator and
answer everything that
we didn't get to.
But somebody was asking, will
there be a port of Auto-Tune
to the Web Audio API?
CHRIS WILSON: A super
interesting question.
So one of my multiple projects
that I have on my I Would Love
To Do This list is an
Auto-Tune-like effect.
Although, of course, Auto-Tune
itself is pretty heavily
patented, I'm sure.
The concept of re-tuning
audio files is a
pretty powerful one.
The main reason that I haven't
gone too deeply looking into
it is, well, first of all,
pitch detection is hard.
I keep uncovering one more layer
of the onion of being on
my way to becoming a digital
signal processing engineer.
But it's still--
I get too deeply into the
technical papers that are all
equations, and I kind
of glaze over.
It's certainly--
anything that you could build in
digital signal processing,
you could push into Web Audio.
I'm hoping that we get some
kinds of that work done
relatively quickly.
I'm looking for volunteers,
too.
PETER LUBBERS: Excellent.
All right, so I think that
pretty much concludes it.
There was one question about
where we can get the
presentation.
So you showed, Chris, and of
course, I will be posting all
of the links for this
presentation on our Google
Chrome Developers
Google+ page.
So definitely check
there after.
And we'll have a link to all
of the material-- so the
GitHub where Chris posted his
source, the presentation that
he gave it at I/O, which
has a lot more
information about Web Audio.
We'll also post there the next
event, when we're going to do
that, in a couple of weeks.
And well, I think that's about
it in terms of questions.
Like I said, we'll definitely
cover any
questions that we missed.
And we'll answer them.
Did you have any other questions
there on the--
JAN LINDEN: No, I think that
pretty much covered
[? everything. ?]
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
Well, with that, I'd like to
thank everyone for tuning in.
And I want to thank Chris
and Jan for the great
information--
excellent, excellent overview.
The next session will be
about how you can use
Web Audio in gaming.
We'll do that in
a couple weeks.
And in the meantime, follow
us on Google+
Chrome Developers Channel.
And that's it.
Thank you for tuning in.
CHRIS WILSON: Thanks, guys.
JAN LINDEN: Thank you.
PETER LUBBERS: Thanks.